we're asked to use the reflection tool
to define a reflection that will map
line segment m e
line segment me onto the other line
segment below so we want to map m e to
this segment over here and we want to
use a reflection let's see let's see
what they expect from us if we want to
add a reflection so if i click on this
it says reflection over the line from
and then we have two coordinate pairs so
they want us to define the line that
we're going to reflect over
with two points on that line so let's
see if we can do that to do that i think
i needed to write something down so let
me get my let me get my scratch pad out
and i copied and pasted the same diagram
and the line of reflection one way to
think about we want to map point e we
want to map point e to this point right
over here
we want to map point m
to this point over here
and so between any point and its
corresponding point on this on the image
after the reflection
these should be equidistant from the
line of reflection this and this should
be equidistant from the line of
reflection this and this should be e and
this point should be equidistant from
the line of reflection or another way of
thinking about it that line of
reflection should contain the midpoint
between these two magenta points and it
should contain the midpoint between
these two deep navy blue points so let's
just calculate the midpoints so
we could do that with a little bit of
mathematics the coordinates for e right
over here that is let's see that is
x equals negative 4
y is equal to
negative 4.
and the coordinates for the
corresponding point to e in the image
this is x is equal to two
x is equal to two and y is equal to
negative six
so what's the midpoint between negative
four negative four and two comma
negative six
well you just have to take the average
of the x's and take the average of the
y's let me do that i'll actually i'll do
it over here so if i take the average of
the x's it's going to be negative 4
negative 4
plus 2
over 2 that's the average of the x's and
then the average of the y's is going to
be negative 4 plus negative 6 over 2
negative 4 plus negative 6
over 2
and then close the parentheses
let's see negative 4 plus 2
is negative 2 divided by 2 is negative 1
so it's going to be negative 1
comma
negative 4 plus negative 6 that's same
thing as negative 4 minus 6 which is
going to be negative 10 divided by 2 is
negative 5
is let me do that blue color so you see
where it came from
is going to be
negative 5. so there you have it that's
going to be the midpoint between
e and the corresponding point on its
image so let's see if i can
if i can plot that so this is going to
be
this point right over here is going to
negative 1 comma negative 5. so x is
negative 1 y is negative 5. so it's this
point right over here and it does indeed
look like the midpoint it looks like
it's equidistant between e and this
point right over here and so this should
sit on the line of reflection so now
let's find the midpoint between m and
this point right over here the
coordinates of m are x is negative 5
and y is equal to 3
the coordinates here are x is equal to
and y is equal to negative 1.
so the midpoint the the x coordinate of
the midpoint is going to be the average
of the x's here so let's see it's going
to be negative 5
plus 7 over 2 and the y coordinate of
the midpoint is going to be the average
of the y coordinates so 3
plus negative 1
over 2. let's see negative 5 plus 7 is
positive 2 over 2 is 1.
minus 1 3 plus negative 1 that's
so the point 1 comma 1 is the midpoint
between these two so 1 comma
1 just like that so the line of
reflection is going to contain these two
points and two points define a line in
fact i could let me draw the line of
reflection just because we did all of
this all of this work the line of
reflection is going to look something
like is going to look something like
oh i need i want to draw this a little
bit straighter than that it's going to
look something like
it's going to look something like
something like this and this makes sense
that this is a line of reflection
uh i missed that magenta point a little
bit
so let me go through the magenta point
okay there you go this makes sense that
this is a line of reflection because you
see that every you pick an arbitrary
point on segment me say
that point and if you reflect it over
this line it's this
this is its shortest distance from the
line you just go on to the other side of
the line in equidistant and you get to
its corresponding point on the image so
it makes a lot of sense these are mirror
images if this is kind of the the mirror
here or you can imagine that this is you
know this is kind of the surface of the
water if you're looking at it at an
angle i don't know if that helps you or
not but anyway we found two points we
found two points that define that line
of reflection so now let's use the tool
to type them in one is negative one
negative five the other one is one comma
one so let me see if i can remember that
i have a bad memory
but so one is
negative one
comma negative five
and then the other one is one comma one
and we see it worked we see it worked by
when i did that it actually made the
reflection happen and notice it
completely went from this point and now
our blue is over the image that we
wanted to get to so we are we are done